two chicks beat JD at armwrestling it
was a man what are you talking about
where were you what happy hour last week
every Friday and do we hide chicks there
and they arm wrestled him like he was
trying to floor were there so he's like
all let's arm wrestle and she kicked his
ass at least he had human contact you
got to touch a girl doesn't that make
you want to hit the gym you know
everything humiliation dude is it
embarrassing like we got a bar and yes
yes everything is embarrassing to me
your arm yeah I'm left-handed I beat her
with the left arm but now it's be able
to beat a chick with anyway oh sorry
Howard
you're alright don't take them out take
them out right now wrong bench over
there alright I want it regulated I want
to judging I don't want anybody lifting
their elbow off all right sir profits
gonna take your ass down right now we
gotta get every girl in the building to
armwrestling let's just take him down
Robin wait all right he's got to get his
left arm he's using that for leverage
Robin take your heels off it both
approach off your balance not bothering
all right are you ready yeah we'll count
it off Rob is gonna take this guy right
down to go look at this Rob is going to
take his essence right now it's even put
your weight into it Robin
jd7 JD sympathy he's using his body use
your body possess down
Rock'em down what happened my arm got
tired your arm got tired your arm got
typing I said his arm got tired
sorry
sorry